we have a packed show today so i want to
get to my first guest
right away because i just got my 2020
ballot sent to me for local elections
the big one the president
i know nothing about politics so i want
to bring on an expert
in politics uh my friend your friend
flew labor lula hello democracy is good
democracy lula can't legally vote in
this country because of his uh
german situation yeah we're calling it
thank you yeah keep it to me
so this is great i have a sticker for
when i finish i feel good about that
so let's go through this ballot um i'm
sure if you live in california you have
one that looks similar if you live in a
different state
maybe your deadline's passed this is
your official election
guide presented by flulaborg
so the first one on the ballot right
here is
uh nithya rahman vs david rue for
los angeles city general municipal
election
member of the city council fourth
district yes uh
what should i fill in well let me tell
you just a little story um so some
backstory ramen
nissi ramen she invented a soup
the ramen soup she's in charge of that
she feels like this has been an ancient
soup it's been around for a while
she seems like a younger woman but was
passed down from the generations
you know like um like like back spasms
[Music]
so let's go with uh los angeles
community college district member of the
board trustees
seat one our options are tori bailey
uh cheney tustin yeah yeah pause um
i will tell you right away always select
someone that has
a nice symbol above a letter in germany
we have umlauts i'm loving those dots
people
so if there are dots or perhaps a little
snippy snappy above
this is who you pick okay so until day
alone
yeah we're gonna go well any day it's
gonna
if you're voting whatever this is this
is thursday sunday till day any day
that's who you select
okay this feels like a crime at this
point this bit feels like we're going
into a crime
judge of the superior court it seems
really important
uh office number 80. our options are
david a
burger or clint james
you know you know just like with mcguire
jerry you had me at
burger it's a delicious thing anything
that sounds like tasty calories
they win my friend johannes sauerkraut
one time ran
for a small a district of education seat
in germany he lost
why nobody eats it okay
[Music]
this one i feel like i've been hearing a
lot in the news a lot of protests i went
to some of these district attorney
uh jackie lacy versus george uh
gascon i can tell you why there is an
issue um lacey is running for the first
time without
her partner cagney and so is the problem
if it was cagney and laci everyone would
be like yay great wonderful times but
because cagney is now i don't understand
what cagney is doing i think running a
fish store
or something so this is the issue is
because acme is not available so she's
running like fifty percent power yeah
essentially yeah
doesn't have lazy cagney it's cagney and
lacy it's cagney and lacy moses it's
cagney lacey okay yeah yeah that seems
like an outdated reference
for a comedy duo that i i do not know oh
google it wow one of the hottest
comebacks of 2009
was google visit
[Music]
state measure 17 we're getting under
measures we're getting down to price
measure twice vote once restores the
right to vote after completion of
a prison term this is an issue
yeah yeah you went to prison you paid
your dose let them vote [ __ ]
measure 19 changes to certain property
tax
rules oh i like that so vague property
owner yes i just recently purchased
three night clubs very cheap
during the pandemic uh so oh this is
about this yes
um i would like to raise all of these
taxes no one is attending my nightclubs
currently i'm djing hardcore no one is
here i would like to punish people
for not coming to my nightclub so yes
you purchased three nightclubs during a
global pandemic lockdown yes i purchased
the one behind the gelsons you know
heartsy tarzis
uh uh yeah where do you think i got my
lip ring hello
and also abcdefps also i purchased
uh just down the stairs you know down
the street from the pf chance on the
promenade and then
i purchased just a whole basement it's a
garden apartment
it was a techno studio and now it's mine
so yes you want to tax anyone that comes
to your club
and doesn't come
we have a big one coming up i think i
think i'm gonna need some help with this
i need some help with my life at this
point so i'm gonna bring on my next
guest if you stick around for a second
you know where from sona fixes your life
and i think she can fix a lot right now
please welcome trustee assistant
sono mo session sona do we have you
she is sit in a pitch black room now ah
there you lost power sauna
from sona fixes your life center we're
going through this ballot and um
i need your help and flula's help we
have the big one coming up okay this is
the official california ballot
um these are our presidential options we
of course have
biden and harris trump and pence
we have uh rocky and i guess
vice president kanye oh which i didn't
did you know he was stepped down to vice
president i didn't know that i thought
he was still president
right well according to this ballot it's
he's he's running as the vice president
so i think even he's trying to distance
himself maybe he realized he's not
qualified enough for president and he's
like i am qualified enough for
vice president i think that was a smart
choice so quote
rocky is more qualified his name is
rocky
is that a human yeah is rocky a human or
is it like a coloring book
literally never heard outside of the bit
never heard of this human being
would you vote for rocky because like
keep in mind the vice president's not
really gonna do a lot um
do you think do you think rocky is
trusty sonia you know what i haven't
seen my ballot yet don't they have
little descriptions
underneath each candidate or am i making
that up
it just says for president i mean under
the the local ones it says like yeah
yeah liberal progressive educator
entrepreneur under president is just
like
this guy's 35 and he'll do it
okay the bar could not be lower the
presidential one yeah
yeah you know what this is the
presidential race is there more is that
it
uh well then there's howie hawkins which
sounds made up it sounds like the name
you give out when you're lying at a
restaurant
um mommy hopkins with angela nicole
walker
and then joe jorgensen and also some
fake
and then jeremy spike cohen
wow i knew a guy on my birthright trip
jeremy cohen i think he's trying to go
by spike
now yeah this is a really tough one
i don't know about you guys but i think
that this might be the
most difficult president to choose
ever ever yeah it's never been clear
like
this has never been more vague who to
select what do you think i would suggest
yeah yeah if you can write somebody in i
would suggest you michael dukakis
yeah he got a raw steel in 1988 was up
very very high and then what happened i
don't know and then boom poof disappears
right the tank and he's gone
michael duke is so are you familiar with
michael dukakis i think it's
a little bit before our time we're in
our 50s yeah michael ducat i mean
yeah i've heard of him well everything
is tape delay in germany so i'd heard
about
michael dukakis in 2018 was kind of a
new
he like had a nice little whoa he's
famous watch out watch out
it's michael duke it's usually not good
when someone's famous and they say
watch out watch out that historically
has not been great
hey michael chicago's
you're right now that i realized a
german man with an accent screaming this
bad idea watch out watch out
it's not just like watch out it's too
dude like he's like his car's backing
into you
as he sexually harasses you all right so
i'm gonna write down michael dukakis i
guess i don't know i
i personally like to choose the
candidate with the best teeth
i'm a big and just for oral hygiene and
literally nothing else there's no other
reason
i would ever choose him over anybody
else it's got to be biden
yeah biden's teeth looks like it when
you have your printer and it runs out of
black ink and just like
the white comes out that's like 60 of
his face it's just those
those big old gams
[Laughter]
so we finished the ballot sony you've
yet to receive your ballot do you know
what to do with your ballot
i think flula knows well step one uh
find a ver no
a local uh creek or riverbed
throw this into the riverbed so we'll
throw these in a river when we get them
and then they flow
down to your local election hall
yeah and then everyone at the election
day they scoop the river like it's like
they're panning for gold
except they're panning for ballots so
just hope they find your ballot
uh as they go streaming down directly
into baja
actually someone's knocking on the door
it sounds
like um ice let me let me see it's
maybe it's oh no
no don't don't don't answer you don't
have to answer
if anyone's watching you don't have to
answer for i okay he's gone
i fooled them guys i told them no german
would own a trombone
yes they're all the ice tracks oh i got
it
hey good luck guys try next door yeah
wait so did you answer
you answered the door with the trombone
and they're like wrong address
i opened the door always and i just go
and as soon as you do this everyone's
like oops harmless
harmless stay so heartless stay
i mean you have tips for people yeah you
should not try that if ice delivers the
door don't go to the door with the
trombone
you know what fools i wrote down the
parts the beginning that made me laugh
the ramen family how it was her family
invented ramen that killed me and you
opened three nightclubs
not one not two three three yeah yes
all good things come in threes and also
all tragedies you don't know until you
try
so this is true wow sound bit
nice that sounds yeah it sounds like a
truth
yeah based on no information yeah three
night clubs i mean we have a place to go
we at least have a shelter
yes oh yeah you guys can sleep and i
will play some nice tasty reggaeton
oh my god the quarantines really hit you
hard when you started playing reggaeton
moses you don't know what you missing
lula borg everyone with your official
guide to the 2020 california ballot
thank you so much who gave us a lot to
go on if you are so welcome moses bye
bye sona you are great
bye flools that was fun this was fun
yeah it's fun that uh we're all
definitely on a watch list now for sure
i might need a new ballot i think i'm
just gonna vote in person
i'm just gonna do it you're gonna brave
it yeah i think i'm just too nervous
but i mean i don't have any reason to be
you could just drop it off at a polling
place and you could track it but i'm
just like too scared
what about after the election are you
worried at all like
whatever the results are some people are
going to be a little unhappy
is there any part of you it's like maybe
i'll get out of a major city i'll get
out of los
angeles i didn't think about that until
right now so thanks for putting that
idea
into my head